located in upper manhattan columbia
university in new york comes in at
number five on this year's top colleges
list
columbia houses three undergraduate
programs
the flagship columbia college the
college of engineering and the school of
general studies which admits
non-traditional students colombia
guarantees housing for all four years
and most students take advantage of it
more nobel laureates have graduated from
or taught at columbia than any other
university in the ivy league at number
four is princeton university in
princeton new jersey princeton is down
one spot from last year's list
students whose families have an annual
income below 65 000 are eligible for a
grant to cover full tuition residential
college fee room and board princeton
meets 100 of demonstrated financial need
for domestic and international students
prince and alumni are high achieving the
university has produced 21 road scholars
over the last decade and 18 total alumni
recipients of the nobel prize
at number three is stanford university
in palo alto california up from number
four on last year's list the
institution's engineering school has
housed some of the most accomplished
innovations of silicon valley families
with annual incomes below 75 000 are not
expected to pay tuition room or board at
number two is uc berkeley in berkeley
california berkeley is down one spot
from last year's list since the free
speech movement of the 1960s berkeley
students have maintained a strong
tradition of involvement in social
justice movements an attitude that
pervades the berkeley spirit to this day
the school is the top producer of peace
corps members and 5 300 students
participate in off-campus public service
programs at number one is the
massachusetts institute of technology in
cambridge massachusetts up from number
six on last year's list
last year researchers at mit filed 439
patents and 25 companies formed using
the school's intellectual property
despite the school's stem focus all
students must complete a wide-ranging
core curriculum which includes
laboratory requirements and a 100 yard
swim test
[Music]